i got to tell you something you got a
minute uh
yes i was chuckling as i was driving
down here
tonight because i remember i was at a
party
either you had it or i had it or maybe
it was even on your show
all my memories of you just kind of
blend together i get it so this clearly
this event meant a lot to you
not really i didn't think so and um i
was wearing a v-neck sweater without a
t-shirt underneath it
and it triggered you for some reason i
did you wouldn't let go of that for
months after that whenever i saw you so
i can't believe you were
the v-neck without the t-shirt under it
yeah
i don't know what the trigger was or why
that was
you are very this you're a very good
looking guy very very good looking but
this area of your body not so great
that's my best quality no and you what i
don't like is when a guy wears a low-cut
v
and no t-shirt it looks cheesy to me
even with the chisel
one pack was chiseled the other one was
no i chiseled both of them
before i got there i made sure they were
both chiseled
you know i'm going to tell you something
i i've i'm going to i'm going to
compliment you at the very top of this
interview and i'm going to say this with
great sincerity you're going to have a
hard time with it
look at me in the eye then when you say
it i'm looking you in the eye and i'm
telling you
that you are one of in my opinion one of
the great
all-time talk show guests you're
fantastic
you think differently you always come
with amazing jokes
you're very funny uh and you have been a
blessing
to all the different shows i have done
and i always wanted to compliment you
up front because i'm going to grow
irritated with you very soon
and uh i'm probably going to just cut
out of the interview fast
so i wanted to get that out of the way
and i appreciate it all my writers
throughout the years whenever you're on
the show
my writers don't watch the show they've
got better things to do than i don't
crap
they gather around the sets when you're
on yes they consider you
an absolute comedy master and i'm i'm
just uh delighted that you could be here
as we sort of wind this nightly thing
down well
you have always and i'm not just saying
this because you said something nice to
me um you have always been a pleasure
to be on your sh it has always been a
pleasure to be on your show because
you are always open to my ideas trying
different things
different bits and then you have good
writers and you yourself contribute
you add on to it and i always walk away
thinking that was funny
and in my um highlight reel
your show is like right up there
what do you mean write it don't say
right up there no it's
right up there that's a compliment but
that could mean right up there with all
the other shows you do that
it's vague enough to to leave me
wondering
what does he mean by right now what i
mean is this and it's a compliment
i threw your name in the hat with some
of the other talk show hosts
and the hat that's right up there on the
top shelf
it's top shelf it's what i'm saying it's
your top shelf
you